on this wednesday night a remarkable
remembrance day
a simple pared-down ceremony in the
nation's capital
the crowd's sparse the mood subdued
pomp and ceremony is not the important
part remembering
that's the important part plus creative
new ways to honor service and sacrifice
a tragic year for canada's military how
veterans are struggling for support
manitobans on edge on the eve of a
lockdown
i lost two jobs yesterday attempts to
get the upper hand on rising covid19
infections
and hospitalizations and the crisis
inside some long-term care homes how the
most vulnerable are falling victim to
the virus
again
global national with donna friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
pandemic is affecting everything in our
lives even how we remember the dead on
this remembrance day
there were no big gatherings no big
crowds around cenotaphs to mark the
sacrifice of the many
who have fallen in the service of their
country and to acknowledge the courage
of those who still serve
in ottawa at the national war memorial
prime minister justin trudeau his wife
sophie
the governor general this year's silver
cross mother
and other dignitaries did attend the
traditional service
but there were no veterans marching no
children's choir singing
instead the lone voice of a young
soloist
[Music]
because it is 2020 what is a shared
moment for so many canadians had to be
observed
in private this november 11th though as
michael couture reports what we are all
enduring made today in some ways
even more powerful
it was the same solemn ceremony with
precautions for a pandemic
the few remaining veterans of the second
world war were asked to stay home
as were members of the public i come
because of my father and my grandfather
and those that have served
are serving now korean war veteran
george slade managed to slip through
security
but he made sure he was respecting
physical distance rules
while paying his respects i've got a
tradition of family and military family
it's not just that the men i've served
with
they're out here i know many of them and
and it's the ones that are not here
and the ones that are disabled
it's the least you can do and it's
something vivian miroyo
had to do to honor her late mother
kenya's first ever female police officer
who also served as a peacekeeper she
always wanted to come here and witness
this
but she never made it because of the
cancer but yeah
today i told them here mom you can see
she loved red
all mothers were represented this year
by national silver cross mother debbie
sullivan
fewer dignitaries laid wreaths in honor
of the fallen and masks covered some of
the anguish and emotion
felt on this day and comforting each
other
was done at a distance
one block south a different kind of
frustration as some strain to get a good
view of the ceremony
if they want to keep civilians out no
problem
but they should at least let veterans in
to be able to observe to be able to
honor their brothers
and sisters the royal canadian legion
wanted it this way limiting the number
of invited guests to just
100 as the country continues to battle
the coronavirus
so while it may have lacked people it
didn't lack meaning
the parade is not the important part
right the pomp and ceremony is not the
important part
remembering that's the important part
remembering those who fought and those
who continue to fight
every day mike lacrouter global news
ottawa
the federal government has promised
veterans millions of dollars in funding
to help them through the pandemic
many are still waiting for benefits and
services there are delays in processing
applications
and that's adding to the stress of an
already difficult year
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson joins me mercedes 2020 has
really been a terrible year of loss for
the canadian military
donna the military has been struck by
tragedy again
and again with eight training deaths
this year alone and it has
sent shock waves through the tight-knit
community
on april 29 a cyclone helicopter
callsign
stalker 22 crashed into the ionian sea
off greece
right after a routine reconnaissance
mission and nato training exercise
the helicopter plunged into the ocean
near the canadian frigate
hmcs frederickton to the horror of the
ship's crew
cutting short the lives of captain kevin
hagen
sub-lieutenant abigail cobra captain
brendan ian mcdonald master corporal
matthew cousins
sub lieutenant matthew pike and captain
maxime
mira moran on may 17th one of the
snowbirds tudor planes crashed
almost immediately after taking off in
kamloops bc
the snowbirds were flying across canada
to lift spirits during the pandemic
on operation inspiration captain
jennifer casey the team's public affairs
officer
was killed in the crash and last month
on october 30th
a training accident during a live fire
exercise at canadian forces base
wainwright in eastern alberta
corporal james choi a reservist with the
royal westminster regiment based in new
westminster bc
was shot and killed donna the deaths
have genuinely shaken those in the
canadian forces
this is a peacetime military and they
weren't expecting it
made even harder by this remembrance day
when they are not able to gather
together
to remember and to mourn mercedes there
is frustration from some veterans about
government promises that still haven't
been kept
bring us up to date on that donna
there's been a lot of promises from
politicians of governments of all
stripes and veterans still feel
they are being forgotten many are at
additional risk because of the pandemic
those with
moral or psychological injuries those
who were already
at risk for homelessness and of course
we continue to see
veteran suicides rise which is a deeply
disturbing fact in this country
right now there are over forty five
thousand veterans waiting to find out a
decision
from veterans affairs canada on the
benefits they've earned
it will take them an average of 36 weeks
to find that out
many veterans say that's too long the
government says that they have put both
money and resources between
to decreasing that but it's not expected
to see the backlog resolved
until 2023. donna right mercedes
stevenson
in ottawa thank you now to the pandemic
as we approach mid-november the second
wave of covet 19 in canada keeps rising
fast
in many regions apart from atlantic
canada ontario reported more than
fourteen hundred new cases today that's
a new record
in quebec more than thirteen hundred
people tested positive and
22 more people have died further west
alberta reported 672 new cases manitoba
431 and 9 more deaths there
this is what the map looks like when you
adjust for population manitoba still has
the most
active cases per capita 394 for every
100
000 people and manitoba's test
positivity rate the percentage of tests
that
come back positive is increasingly
alarming it's hit
10.7 percent toronto by comparison had a
test positivity rate yesterday of
5.9 percent manitoba is about to enter a
code red
lockdown as of midnight social
gatherings are banned and non-essential
businesses will have
to close covet 19 is now spreading so
fast through the community and
through some care homes that the
situation in manitoba is the worst it
has been since the pandemic began
brittany greenslade reports from
winnipeg
manitoba's health care system is at a
tipping point escalating covet 19 cases
and out of control community spread
has left manitobans preparing for
another province-wide lockdown
everybody's tensed up you know we all
know what's going on everybody's still
kind of nervous and
a little chaotic the lines outside
grocery stores have already started as
further restrictions loom
at midnight non-essential businesses
will be forced to close their doors
and while students will remain in school
it feels eerily similar to the spring
lockdown
many hoped wouldn't come back this
closure feels
extremely different it feels more
pressing it's
it's at a crucial time for probably all
businesses in the city i
lost two jobs yesterday so that's
definitely something that made me feel a
little uneasy going forward
but the province says the virus's
crippling effects have left no other
options
two dozen care homes in winnipeg now
have outbreaks including
maples which is home to the province's
largest on friday night
paramedics responded to 18 911 calls
eight people died within 48 hours the
events of the last few days at maple's
personal care home
as we've come to learn can really only
be described as sickening
in just the last month manitoba's test
positivity rate
tripled now hitting 10.7 percent
hospitalizations are four times higher
with 218 people
now in need of urgent care and nearly
100 more people have died
scared scared we got to put a curve to
it i feel that
you know if we can all cooperate
together to try to save some lives it's
it's good i work in long-term care and
we've been hoping that this would happen
just to kind of get the cases a little
bit lower and keep everybody safe
and hopefully get manitoba's second wave
under control
ahead of the holidays brittany
greenslade global news
winnipeg in saskatchewan more than 300
doctors from across the province are
calling for action they've written a
letter to premier
scott mo and the province's top medical
officer the doctors say
it is becoming increasingly clear to us
that we are losing the battle against
this virus
if more is not done to change our course
we are confident that winter will bring
overflowing hospitals canceled surgeries
overwhelmed
health care providers and needless
deaths
saskatchewan's health minister has
thanked the doctors for that letter and
said he is relying on the advice
and guidance of the province's top
doctor
across the country there are also calls
to do more and
fast to protect canadians in long-term
care despite promises to do better after
the devastation in the spring there are
multiple
outbreaks again and more deaths in
several provinces
in ontario there are outbreaks in more
than 90 long-term care homes now
in the last 24 hours 24 more residents
were reported to have died eric sorenson
has more
on the troubling trends and why lessons
were not learned have we let our guard
down
exposing the most vulnerable among us
all over again
the elderly and long-term care homes in
edmonton's south terrace continuing care
center
one case three weeks ago became 146
cases
including 70 staff and 76 residents 10
of whom have died
karen steiner's dad is there he has
advanced alzheimer's and she cannot see
him these are very vulnerable patients
they're going to die from neglect is
what i fear the family is really
concerned about it and we can't go in we
can't see them we can't skype we can do
nothing
it's one thing to accept rising case
numbers among the young to keep the
schools and the economy functioning
but there is a risk in doing so the more
community spread we have
the more outbreaks are going to happen
in our care homes and the more deaths
we're going to see
and a stark reminder that currently 97
percent
of those who died of covet 19 in canada
are older canadians
at kennedy lodge in toronto 29 residents
have passed away since early october
the trend in ontario is unmistakable the
number of active covet 19 cases and care
homes
has risen from fewer than 300 last month
to more than 600 in recent days
the number of cases among staff has
risen steadily to more than 400
and the most troubling statistic the
death toll among residents
on average there were two deaths per day
during early and mid-october
now an average of 10 deaths a day over
the last week
including 24 deaths yesterday
ontario's budget last week was
criticized for lacking details on
promised funding to improve long-term
care
dr sinha is blunt more staff are needed
at the same time
many of them are getting sick especially
when a home is in an outbreak
that they continue having the necessary
staffing to make sure that the residents
are getting the care they need
in montreal the heron care home was
woefully understaffed last spring
when 38 residents died now it is closing
down residents will be moved but that is
not a solution across the country
where residents and staff of long-term
care homes see a deadly disease
making a comeback eric sorensen global
news toronto
president trump's denial of the election
results coming up legal experts weigh in
on his claims
of voter fraud
president donald trump emerged from the
white house today to observe
veterans day in the united states
he attended a ceremony at the tomb of
the unknown soldier in arlington
national cemetery in virginia trump and
the first lady arrived late
and he made no remarks president trump
is still refusing to concede to
president-elect
joe biden trump and his team are
challenging the results with lawsuits
and recounts as jackson proskow reports
the allegations of voter fraud just
don't add up in georgia where just 14
000 votes separate joe biden from donald
trump they're undertaking a manual
recount of all 5 million ballots
just to be sure this will help build
confidence it will be an audit
a recount and a re-canvas all at once
confidence is in question as the trump
campaign continues to challenge the
election using a scatter shot strategy
of false allegations about voter fraud
the most important thing to know is that
republicans and democrats
supervise the election and indeed many
of the states complain about are run by
republicans
in pennsylvania a postal worker came
forward with allegations of backdated
mail-in ballots
he later recanted his story before
recanting again
in michigan the trump campaign filed a
234-page lawsuit alleging wrongdoing
based on affidavits from republican poll
watchers
including claims that the workers were
not able to properly view ballot
counting due to covet 19 restrictions
one man says he suspected fraud with
military ballots
because he was doubtful that they would
have voted for joe biden so a lot of
this is public relations
the remedies they seek stop everything
or hold another election that's not
going to happen
and what about the ever popular claim
that thousands of dead people
voted it hasn't panned out experts
acknowledge a small number of
irregularities are possible
are we talking about half a dozen are we
talking about a dozen are we talking
about 20
these are incredibly ordinary uh sorts
of problems to have with any large-scale
electoral system
none of it would change the outcome of
the election in trump's favor
but that may not be the end goal a new
poll finds eight in ten republicans now
believe
biden's win is illegitimate as the
president and his allies work to
manufacture doubt
and that could leave the president-elect
facing a very steep
uphill battle on day one 70 days from
now
donna jackson thanks
starry salute still ahead and out of
this world tribute to the fallen in the
uk
in london only a select few attended an
armistice day service in westminster
abbey
because of the pandemic the public was
discouraged from gathering its cenotaphs
but as crystal gomencing explains people
still found a way to pay tribute to the
fallen
by looking to the stars the twinkling
lights
beckon you to click the stars are
stories
some are brief sharing only a name
others
include service records you can just
name a star after them and it appears in
this virtual universe that we've created
by writing the names of veterans in the
sky the commonwealth war graves
commission
hopes to educate and connect people
peter francis was able to accompany two
veterans an
88 year old and an 81 year old on a
virtual
starry stroll and the whoops of joy i
got on the other end of the line when
they saw the start
absolutely made my heart warm and it
just made
all of the hard work behind the campaign
worthwhile
this year people were not only
discouraged from gathering in big groups
at cenotaphs
many weren't able to even pin on a poppy
instead britons were encouraged to
donate online
and print one out this year we haven't
set a target because
the the environment is just so different
but what we do know is that since the
lockdown
since we've had to cancel the
face-to-face collections for the first
time 100 years
we know that we will be taking a loss in
the in the realm of millions
[Music]
inside westminster abbey only a handful
of people were permitted to attend a
service at the grave of the unknown
warrior
with england in the middle of another
lockdown the abbey is closed to visitors
[Applause]
many had hoped this armistice day would
be the in-person
gathering the nation was deprived of in
may
victory in europe celebrations were
cancelled because of the first lockdown
still people are trying to honor all of
those who have served
and sacrificed we're not letting it pass
away that torch of remembrance is still
burning brightly and strongly
burning and lighting the way to explore
the cosmos
and learn the name of the stars crystal
gomansing global news
london next honoring canada's vulnerable
veterans
remembrance day ceremonies are usually a
time for veterans to gather together
share stories and be honored by the
public as mike derolay reports this
year's scale back events meant a very
different
experience for our vets alex paulowin
can't help but feel lonely
he's the last of the brave crew of the
hmcs huron a destroyer that helped clear
the english channel ahead of d-day
every remembrance day he's reminded of
that fact
i think i'm about the only man left
standing on the last ship that i was on
you know it's it's a sad feeling you
know that
knowing that they're all gone the
reminders of his generation disappearing
are
far too frequent last week bc's george
chow
who fought both racism at home and the
nazis in europe
died at the age of 99 they think about
their mortality
about the impact they made on this world
and with the pandemic forcing 375 vets
to stay inside
at sunnybrook hospital's veterans center
in toronto
they worry mistakes that were made could
be repeated
you have to have friends die in the lord
to realize what war is all about
unless you've had that experience it's
hard to
it's hard to believe what the
significance of wars
are the drone of four canadian harvard's
cut the silence of a scaled back
remembrance day in toronto
from coast to coast to coast canadians
were reluctantly urged to stay away
[Music]
that led to a smallish crowd in halifax
and so few people in montreal you might
miss it if you drove past
virtual broadcasts like this one in
winnipeg for all their good intentions
were heartbreaking to see and while the
vets at sunnybrook could only look out
their windows
their view was a glorious sea of
canadian flags
100 for each of the 375 still there
thirty seven thousand five hundred in
total one veteran told me a story about
how his best friend from childhood had
gone off to war with him
and his best friend had been killed in
battle
and he pointed out to the flags on our
lawn and said but now he's here with us
it wasn't the ceremony they deserved but
at least it reminded them
we haven't forgotten microlight global
news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday remembrance day i'm donna
friesen
we leave you tonight with more tributes
to canadians who have served and
sacrificed for our country
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
we're called the caring
canadians i think
that's a wonderful legacy
to have
[Music]
[Music]
sorry